[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back to
binging with babish where this week
we're taking
the whoa taking a look at me i guess oh
my hello my name is andrew ray aka
binging with babish and i'm here to
answer your questions via twitter
this is cooking support
[Music]
at ndwelch asks why do they always use
kosher salt in cooking videos
well i'll tell you nathan there are
really three salts that you need to know
about there is
table salt the one that you're probably
most familiar with kosher salt
and flaky finishing salt i like to call
table salt baking soda because that's
really all i use it for because most
recipes are developed using
table salt but that being said it's not
a great way to season your food when
you're cooking
because you can't pinch it kosher salt
on the other hand you have complete
control over
so you can see right now i have a big
old pinch full of it and there's no salt
coming out
of my fingers until i start to twist my
fingers
from left to right it's also a more
forgiving salt
it's a bigger grain of salt you're less
likely to over salt your food
than you would be with table salt and
then this is the totally optional salt
these are very light flaky
look really all you use it for is
finishing that's why it's called
finishing salt these two though
absolute necessities just know when to
use them and why and how
all in all caps people don't keep eggs
in the fridge
don't they go bad faster as far as i
understand
and please take what i'm saying with
several grains of salt
because this is your food safety we're
talking about here and you shouldn't
trust a guy
who doesn't have food safety
certification never went to culinary
school went to film school
got really bad grades and kind of lucked
into his uh job as a food influencer you
shouldn't be listening to me the eggs
that you need to refrigerate are ones
that have been
commercially washed here in the states
they wash eggs
with great rigor and that strips away
the sort of natural protection on the
outside of the shell
so they must be refrigerated if you got
them from the side of the road and they
were not in the fridge
chances are they just came out of a
hen's ass and they're ready
to stay at room temperature in your
stylish
barn converted backsplash kitchen anyway
that old davey boy uh cooking twitter
what are some
good knives that won't immediately break
the bank well i'll tell you
sorry i do have a line of cookware out
okay
it's called the babish cookware line all
right the the okay
these are german steel knives they're
full tang blades
they are 4116 german steel they come
sharp they keep an edge and they're 25
bucks 25 to 30 dollars per knife that
being said i'm not here just
to hook my cookware huck is that the
word i'm not just here
to sling cookware i'm also going to be
fully honest about
other brands that i like victoria knox
fibrox makes a great starter knife it is
stamped not
forged uh likewise with vustoff's pro
line
it's so cheap it's 20 for a knife it's a
great learning knife it's a great
starter knife
but these knives are great too follower
of dole
says time to ask a chef when i make
fluffy scrambled eggs
and cheese fluffy is i tried to make an
omelette and screwed it up
my dish is oily i think it's oil from
the cheese because the eggs are
cooked fully but it's kind of butter
buttery flavor it's good but how to fix
so i'm guessing you're doing is adding
the cheese too early so it's getting too
much heat
from the pan so it's going beyond the
point of melting and it's breaking when
it breaks this basically means that the
the oil just seeps out of it what i
would do is try to add your cheese as
late as humanly possible
just don't overheat it and don't use
cheeses that are too old you know use a
gruyere
or a not too sharp chip pretty mild
cheddar because they're better melters
they're going to stand up to the heat
better
tablespoon and a half of butter in the
pan eggs
always crack on a flat surface then
throw the pan back on the heat before
it gets in the pan i'm gonna beat these
guys up
i'm gonna use a tiny whisk they're more
homogeneous now so now we're going to
add them to the pan keep them moving
keep the pan moving keep the eggs moving
you put this on
toast and it's almost spreading there we
go that's done
irish cheddar put a fair amount in there
this is probably
two ounces yeah two ounces ish we're
just
mixing them in there keeping them moving
and letting the residual heat in the pan
melt the cheese and incorporate them
into the egg this is how i like my
scrambled eggs you might not like them
this way i like them creamy i like them
spreadable and no matter how
you like your scrambled eggs if you add
your cheese at the end
and don't heat the cheese directly on
the stove top you will notice that
there is not a hint of oil or grease in
this pan it is just egg and cheese
nothing has separated and that's how you
prevent
cheese from breaking at duchess wood all
said
okay what y'all season your rib eyes
with salt and pepper man
salt and pepper for the most part you're
just hitting it with salt and pepper
maybe a sauce or something on the on the
back end steak seasonings the shakers
and all that stuff
not so much before boss nine says people
give me
all of your advice on how to cook large
slabs of meat so it won't dry out
the dog is now getting my three pound
pork roast because i dried it out a lot
of things could be happening here
first off you might be cooking it at too
high a temperature you might be just
cooking it for too long
pork you can cook to a rosy 135
if you know where the pork is from and
if you trust it otherwise cook it to 145
it's still going to be nice and rosy and
pink in the middle
and it's going to be super juicy
something like a
pork loin which doesn't have much extra
muscular fat you need to be very careful
to make sure that you're not overcooking
it because that's how it dries out very
fast if you overcook it by 10 degrees
it's gonna be dry as a bone you need to
cook slowly
gently with big big joints of meat the
best way to make
prime rib for example is to cook it at
like 250 degrees fahrenheit for like
six hours also yeah pull the meat 10
degrees shy of where you want it to end
up it will come up
10 more degrees at least when it comes
out of the oven at hawaiian sea witch
if you're cooking shrimp dot dot dot why
do you leave the tails on why
it's so inconvenient when you're
eating and you have to use your hands to
pick off the tails to make sure you get
all the shrimp out yes i just recently
had shrimp pasta and i'm mad about it it
is absolutely inconvenient you're right
to be mad about it
having shrimp tails on and pasta is
ridiculous because
if you don't want to eat with your hands
you're out of luck you have to use your
hands in some capacity
if you've got shrimp tails on that or
you're or you're spitting them out like
an olive pit
which i don't think you want to do in a
fancy restaurant so shrimp tails and
pasta makes
zero sense to me i completely agree that
can really go for itself
from at gymkuras one are hashtag bay
leaves a hoax
i've been cooking with them for 30 plus
years and i'm not sure why
the only thing i know about them is that
they're not actually supposed to be
eaten
cooking question i personally don't
fully know what they're for
either these mysterious bastards from
what i understand
they're supposed to lighten up otherwise
very heavy dishes like stews and braises
they also play really well with seafood
you're not supposed to eat them
obviously but if you want to see what
they taste like
yeah you just gotta sit down
yeah there's a minty almost basily
yeah you're not supposed to eat them but
they do play really well in stews and
braises and if they are a hoax they're
the weirdest hoax i've ever heard of
because these things cost like 99 cents
a ton jillbean aka at
jellybean hardest fruit to cut mango
anyone beg to differ
come prove me wrong hashtag struggling
is there a harder fruit to cut
nope i just ran through the entire list
of fruits in my head uh mango is a very
difficult fruit to cut
you could peel it first but i like to
just kind of go at it kind of like an
avocado
you want to try to get really as close
to the pit as possible it's thinner than
you think
same thing on the other side really
straddle the pit you're going to want to
very carefully
score this guy you see that sort of
spread apart
mango action and now that you've spread
it open like this you can just kind of
chop it out try not to take in the skin
with you but you can just sort of slice
it off there
if i had to sum up the technique it's
like a modified avocado with the avocado
of course you remove the pit
for this you have to be just a little
bit more you know ready to lose some
fruit and
ready to just have some weird oblong
pieces like this guy
megan spencer at the real megan s at
binging with babbage this was actually
for me
that binging with babish i've tried your
bagel recipe from steven universe
twice now and they don't brown up as
much as yours and are only bubbly and
browned on parts that touch the baking
sheet
i have a traditional oven not a
convection do i need to be baking at
higher than 425 fahrenheit
i would say that's a good place to start
another really important thing would be
to make sure that the rack in your oven
is in the right spot
if they're only browning on the bottom
i'm guessing your rack is towards the
bottom of the oven especially if you
have an electric oven that has the
heating element on the bottom they're
getting blasted with heat on the bottom
but not so much on the top so if you put
that rack
in the top third of your oven that's
going to get a lot more radiant heat
off the top of your oven bouncing down
onto the bagels it's going to help brown
them more efficiently they definitely do
brown better
with a convection oven but you can still
make amazing bagels without convection
another great thing to try is the home
steam oven method which is to place a
heat proof
dish or skillet underneath the in the
rack below
the one that you're gonna be baking on
let it preheat with your oven let it get
nice and hot and then when you put the
bagels in the oven
pour some boiling water into that vessel
whatever it is and that's gonna generate
a whole lot of steam
in your oven which is going to allow
your bagels to rise more before they
start to form
a crust before they start to brown
that's going to give you not only a
better oven spring
it's going to give you a better crust so
try moving your your oven rack up to get
more heat coming down from the top and
try
the oven steam method let me know how it
goes tag me goddess betty jane
at bye betty 2. what do you think is the
worst food you could eat in the tub
biscotti wasn't a great idea but i'm
contemplating leftover pad thai
both terrible ideas i totally agree bad
ideas
anything crummy or saucy pad thai would
would be not great but i think a worse
one would be any kind of red sauce
a croissant would be terrible to eat in
a
in a bath especially we have a beard
it's just a croissant catcher
i think the moral of the story is here
you know keep uh only eat corn dogs in
the bath
it's portable one hand i really think
that corn dogs are the best bathtub food
and apples if you're trying to be
healthy at mattias carpenter says
is there something about zesting a lemon
that i don't understand or are we all
just ending up with
the lemon stuck in the grater you're not
imagining anything that's absolutely
what happens i like a rasp style grater
like this one this allows the lemon to
fall out a little bit more freely
first off you don't want to you don't
want to grate too close to the pith
you just want the outermost layer of the
lemon you don't want
the white stuff underneath the stuff
directly on the outside just the zest
that's where the lemon flavor is it's
sweet it's mild it's not bitter you're
still gonna end up with a whole bunch
stuck in there but all you gotta do
that's it no big deal sarah s.o teach me
question when cooking risotto a glug or
a gluggle
of wine is a correct and appropriate
measure right
absolutely risotto is a very imprecise
process
it's something that you really need to
sort of feel out if you put
a half a bottle of wine in there or half
a cup of wine in there
it's still gonna taste good and a glug
is a great way to do it
generally with like you know a standard
batch of risotto i'm putting like a cup
of white wine in there
so i would say more of a gluggle than a
glug because that's like a
[Music]
maybe four glugs and i would call that a
gluggle
that sounds like a gaggle of glugs at
securitysphinx asks what is the best
cocktail garnish and why is it a luxardo
cherry
i completely agree with you it is a
luxardo cherry why is it luxardo cherry
because luxardo cherries
are worth every penny of the like
freaking twenty dollars that a jar
costs they are rich they don't taste
cloyingly sweet
they have the perfect texture to them
they're not mushy
but they have a little bit of a snap the
syrup is
dark and rich and sweet and and and
luxuriant
and i always like to use it in my old
fashions as my simple syrup because it's
very very sweet
and it adds that wonderful luxardo
flavor to my cocktail
so absolutely the best cocktail garnish
100 unless we're talking about bloody
marys in which case
everything's the best cocktail garnish
boston888
asks lately i've been cooking a lot with
onions and wow
the thing about them making you cry is
not a joke
does anyone have any solutions to this
problem i've tried running them under
water a bit doesn't work
i think i'm thinking more like the onion
goggles phil wears in modern family that
is really is like the only
solution is uh got onion goggles like th
that's a thing where
your swimming goggles and those will
work fine there's really not any other
way maddie mathison attests that it's
you need a sharp knife which
there's something to that because the
sharper your knife is the fewer cell
walls in the onion you're rupturing so
it should in theory
not make you cry as much but it also
just totally depends on the onion
i think fridging them might help like
i've always fridged my onions
and i feel like they've made me cry less
than
most other people's onions wear some
goggles if you want to be a dork about
it otherwise
you know suck it up and get it over with
as fast as possible without chopping off
a finger
at good luck crunch what is the best
sandwich
i'm thinking it's got to be the homemade
blt sandwich with mayo
truly food of the gods i love a blt it
is one of the simplest sandwiches you
can get
however i can't say it's the best
sandwich
my favorite sandwich is very close to
the liz lemon
which is you know you got some pastrami
you got some turkey you got some
coleslaw
russian dressing potato chips you got a
lot of crunch in there
i think that even a blt can be improved
though you could throw a runny egg on
there you could throw a slice of cheese
on there a little bit of gruyere or
something like that
nice fresh crisp lettuce toast the
inside of your bread
this is what you should take away from
my long-winded meandering answer
toast the inside of your bread not the
outside it will spare the roof of your
mouth but you'll get all the crunch and
all the flavor
and it will prevent your bread from
getting soggy and to me that's a better
blt it's blt
plus good at caden bop asks how often do
we really need to sharpen knives when
cooking
how often do you bingeing with babbage
that's me
is it like after each use like some
people or should be more like once a
week or even a month
definitely the latter uh you don't need
to sharpen it after each use
depends on how often you're cooking if
you're cooking for yourself every night
every meal
yeah once a week you're probably going
to want to give it a sharp and if you're
if cooking is more of a hobby if you're
cooking on the weekends
i mean i sharpen them probably once a
month
it also depends on the knife you have if
your knife doesn't hold an edge very
long
you need to sharpen it more often
likewise with a honing rod
lots of folks think that this is a knife
sharpener not so
this is a honing rod your blade not only
needs to be kept
sharp it needs to be kept straight so
use the honing rod to straighten out
your edge not going to make your knife
sharp but it's going to help your knife
perform maybe get one of those little
hand sharpeners to tide you over and
then once every few months
get it professionally sharpened or use a
wet stone if you
are a crazy person like me and have
several wet stones
at women enjoy beer asks cooking
substitution question
can i sub evaporated milk for coconut
milk i'm not entirely sure
it really depends on what you're making
in baking especially i can't
recommend that you do that i can't
imagine that they interact the same way
in baked goods i can definitely imagine
situations where you could swap them out
but it's going to totally depend on what
you're making and i'm sorry i don't have
more information there you guys should
have asked an actual expert
at mandel organa let's start this
discourse because
cicely and i whoever cicely is uh need
answers
who in star wars would be a good cook
that's a great question let's run down
the list okay
leia i don't think so because she is a
boss general she doesn't have time to
cook luke
uh i i i could see him cooking but it
would be like gross yoda stuff it'd be
root leaf stew out in the woods
in that weird island planet where he
lives i don't think he cares that much
about food i think food is more of like
a survival like
like sustenance thing for him han no way
darth vader no
he's getting his nutrients through a
tube or some weird he's eating
electricity or something
chewy maybe i mean he's the one of the
few people that has cooked in the movies
like from the star wars christmas
special there is like a whole cooking
segment i think it was
um stewed bantha or something like that
hey guys thank you so much for all the
amazing questions thank you wired for
having me
this has been cooking support
you